well Russia's President Vladimir Putin
says the situation demonstrates the
failure of US policy in the
region unfortunately we can see a sharp
deterioration of the situation in the
Middle East I think that many will agree
with me that this is a clear example of
the failure of the policy of the United
States in the Middle East which tried to
monopolize the resolution of the
conflict but unfortunately wasn't
concerned with finding compromises
acceptable to both sides on the contrary
it promoted its own ideas about how this
should be done put pressure on both
sides first on one side then on the
other every time without taking into
account the fundamental interests of the
Palestinian people bearing in mind first
of all the need to implement the UN
Security Council decision on creation of
an independent Sovereign Palestinian
state